I'm alone like a lot of times in the
python Community or in the you know the
computer science community so it means
well it's just jit so just in time
compiler so what does that mean like
just in time is it like well I'm for
example I I always work just in time I'm
like just you know just in time to have
this presentation already but it doesn't
mean that way right like this is does it
mean that oh your coat just like
finished compiling in time uh no
actually
um so we have to step a little bit back
from like how Computer Works how
computer programming works I know some
of you are you know expert and maybe
like no more than me but just so that
everybody on the same page uh so python
actually does not compile any code uh
you know kind of like uh difference from
what other
I I say lower level language like C or
those like you have to compile the code
right if because I learned a little bit
of C and C plus first when I was in
school now I can't do any of those so
you have to I remember you have to like
you know write your code you know in
with the syntax and then you save it as
a file then you have to compile it
before you can run the code so that's
how those programming work
but python does not work that way python
does not compile programs uh by default
uh so python actually is an interpreter
so what python does is that when python
read your file with your dot Pi file it
will uh interpret it into C code and you
know there's already some compile C code
through the
the uh the see password API all the
stuff and then it would just run the
code that way
so
um
why why do python do it that way uh
there are multiple Reasons I'm not going
to dive into it but uh what are the
difference is that when you compile the
code actually it takes time to compile
the code
um
again like back in the old days when I
have to compound my C code before I can
run a program so it usually take a while
to compile the code but after compiling
the code the code runs super fast right
the the compiled version actually is
already in a even lower in an even lower
kind of level of code so it's like uh
it's for example you compile it to
machine code so your computer chip will
already understand that and run that
direction so it's super fast
so back to what is just in time compiler
so just in time compiler is means that
when you run the program
so for example you run the Python
program but some of them you
make them into the
jit right like you kind of uh when when
it got run you will see that oh actually
wait a second you have this function and
then you're running it multiple times
how about that right how about a
compounded the first time for you so the
second time the third time the fourth
time and the rest of it it will be super
fast so that's the idea so that's why
Jay Kampala can really speed up if you
have a lot of Loops in your code
um so it's number is not the only thing
that do jig compiling for example have
you heard of Pi Pi uh not not the Pi Pi
the registry but like it's another
version of python it's called Pi Pi so
they also use the cheat compiler to
speed things up anyway I'm not going to
too much detail to make it very
confusing you know you know we can talk
about that after if you're interested
about the chicken parlor
so a number is a j compiler but it's
specially designed for numpy so that's
what it says in the beginning right
um so it does those magic things you see
that oh you have loops in your program
your function got used multiple times it
will compile the first time for you and
then make it fast but what makes number
difference from other object Impala is
that it's designed for numpy so uh the
numpy thing are supposed to be working
very very well with number and it
it's uh that's why your your code
especially when you're handling data or
you're doing scientific programming is
it can be speed up with number
and also if you have a lot of looping um
you will see at the exercise that like
when we are running code that dualist
looping it would actually get some speed
up speeding boosts from number
so uh some a little bit like basic
things about number for those of you
have never used it before I number have
two modes you can do so there's object
mode
and there's a no python mode so but
object most uh I would say it's more
like loose there's not that straight so
no python mode you should I'm more
straight so the object will because
object will still use python or so it
can still handle python objects it will
still you know it will still remain the
the python the python API you know the C
python API and stuff so uh but the thing
is that it's not that fast because all
the speed up
uh from the part that we compiled the
code into low level code and and and
then this you know the second set time
you run it is super fast right but if we
are still hanging on to the python API
it's still kind of more or less work
like python right it doesn't compile
anything so it's not as fast
so what it does is that
if you have object mode uh it will kind
of like be a compromise so if your code
is very you know python dependent you
have used a lot of python object that is
not supported by the no 5mo it won't be
very fast it just like do what python
does but if it sees that you have
certain part of your code that can be
using the no python mode to compile to
make it faster than it will do it so uh
I would say that it's very beginner
friendly because you know it's not that
straight you won't run into areas like
the no python mode uh but it will speed
it up for you if you want to speed uh if
you if it can speed it up for you but
the downside is that you if you don't
check it all the time you're not sure
that whether your code is really fast or
not so here's a trade-off so again no
pivot mode is the back and brother of of
a number so it is
why it's much faster it does not use the
C python API not USC API is just take
that
bit that it's compatible that do a lot
of looping so we take it and then you
know restructure the whole kind of uh
the buy code is how python execute like
if we structure that and then make it uh
compiled it into some like kind of low
level things that can be really fast so
if your your code can be compounded no
python mode so it's more promising that
it will be fast
okay
so uh to use the object mode the mode
that we are using python it is the
decorated jit so just at jit
um
so that that's the object mode it will
you know it will fall back into object
mode if you have object that can't be
compiled then you just run in object
mode and
um yeah so sometimes you know when
you're really struggling you can't make
it work with no python mode so try it
with object mode maybe it will work
there's another decoratorical engine so
that is using no python mode
um it's actually a shorthand because
the jet you know add jet The Decorator
it actually works for everything but if
you want to use no python mode you have
to put no python equals the true for the
setting there so sometimes you know if
you have a lot of things you don't want
to type no python it goes to True every
time you can just use engine instead
um so it's scary high performance like I
said uh if it doesn't compile it doesn't
have well guaranteeing in a sense that I
I think I should really uh make it clear
right here that it does not give you
high performance but it if it compiles
it guarantee that it's uh compiled so
sometimes you may not see the the
Improvement in speed because of other
reasons you will see an exercise later
there may be other reasons that make it
like oh why is it doesn't really like us
to speak but it guarantees that it's
compiled and you could take advantage of
the compilation
uh possibly so
um if it if it's not supported you will
get an error message from number saying
like sorry it can't compound in no
python mode so a lot of times when it
happened uh if you're really well I mean
if you really read the performance you
may have to evaluate the code to see
like oh what part that does not compile
you might have to change how you your
code work a little bit so it got
compiled but if you just want to make it
work you don't care about the speed then
you can just use jit and then hope that
it works
so I we will go through those in
exercise as well so don't worry if it
sounds very crazy at the moment
so
another thing I want to mention but we
won't dive into it in this kind of
beginner's friendly tutorial is that uh
number also support the uh the GPU the
gpus so uh for example if you like you
use GPU because you have lots of data to
handle speed is very important because
you're doing something like deep
learning or things like that
then uh number may be a very good tool
that you could try because uh it's you
know already designed to work with a
Cuda GPU
um so you know sometimes you know
because of like the gpus like actually
work differently actually like each chip
Works differently so for for the cooler
GPU sometimes it's like it's uh you you
can't just run python code like directly
so you need to have a lot of like
intermediate steps so it's not very fast
but uh with number it would allow it to
be compiled into something that can have
direct access so it will be compatible
and it'll be fast but anyway the details
I will Target you know I won't give you
too much detail about it if you really
want to know more uh go to the there's a
talk there the link actually is
collectible here
um the link for this slider is in the
GitHub repo so you'll find it or you can
just search like find it at Amsterdam
you know number there's there's a talk
by the maintainer and there will be
details there
so uh one last thing that is quite
important is to have the dog ready
before you dive into the exercise so uh
this is uh
the the read the dogs uh you know the
official documentation so I'm just
reminding you like I know it's just oh
it's just a documentation yeah but I'm
reminding you that if you have questions
don't panic if it doesn't work don't
panic check the documentation sometimes
it helps
um but I'm here so you can also ask me
for help as well I'll be scattering
around the room so you know I can help
I'm thinking so what do people feel like
I I can actually I can talk I thought
that I'm going to be coughing like crazy
so I cannot talk so maybe maybe we can
go through the first
um
the first notebook together do people
prefer that or do you want to work on it
by yourself
a silence
together together okay so I will have to
get my juvenile notebook running again
so I might you know blackened the screen
a little bit but go to this uh go to
this link get the get all the materials
first and then I'll get myself ready and
then we can run the first notebook
together okay so
oh sorry I have to go back here so you
will see my very very messy desktop yes
yeah and my computer is super slow today
so
bear with me if you want to start by
yourself you can start by yourself don't
uh you don't have to wait for me
oops
foreign
okay
do I have to press any buttons or it
would project again
hmm
don't think this is the problem
any technician in the room no
okay let me try it
yeah and plug and plug it in again but
it seems like it's not happy
oh maybe now it's working I don't know
wow yeah sorry okay okay now okay
sorry about that I was not planning to
well I'm kind of like debating whether I
should do it but yeah it's not not well
prepared you see um I just prepared just
in time see
Okay so
yeah bad jokes I know so if you have
downloaded the repo and open it with
Jupiter notebook Jupiter lab I'm still
using Jupiter notebook I'm a very simple
person I like being simple but you can
YouTube the lab if you want to
um it's up to you so uh just have them
running
um we'll go for the first one together
there's number two and number three
there are some kind of quizzes inside
like oh you have to code and figure it
out yourself but these are the solutions
so um don't cheat don't look at it yet
but when the time when you get stuck you
can look at it
um yeah the notebook will guide you so
don't worry
um also included a tutorial from numpy
actually because the last notebook kind
of uh used that so it may help if you do
this first and then kind of understand
what it works originally and then work
on the the last one but
anyway up to you so let's go to the
first one oh okay
scares me a little bit so let's go to
the first one
um
so uh let's just start from scratch uh I
just assumed that people may not have
number or numpy so you can keep in store
if you want but I have already installed
so I'm not going to run that cell
um but yeah run that cell if you don't
have number or you you know you can just
cross out numpy if you already have
numpy
so that's the main thing we're gonna use
um
and we are not we are not trying it on
other things like pandas because number
is designed for numpy even though I know
that pandas use numpy as the the
backbone but
it may not work right this doesn't
guarantee they will work so so let's use
numpy as an example here uh so before we
like you know get into too much trouble
so
uh so yeah that may be typo here because
you know it's it's not so if they're
typos just bear with me let me know I'll
fix it uh in the future so um
this is the 101 example here so what we
have here is that we have a few
functions it's just doing something very
very simple it's doing a
a
tangent uh something I forgot what is it
called like the the tangent of it some
kind of medical calculation so um so we
have here we have the normal one which
like we don't use the we don't use num
number we don't use like we just vanilla
it's just like what what is it is
without the without the speeding boost
um oh I should not have this here yeah
so like I said there's a lot of typo and
stuff I'll fix that in the future just
for me
um this one we don't we don't use the
jit so this one we use the jit so
um here you see that uh we have to
import the jit so uh because it's a
decorator it's defined inside number so
you have to import it
and then uh non-class MP we all know
this time is just used to time this
thing so we can have a comparison
um so we have the normal and then we
have to go fast and then
but why Gophers run twice uh reason
being that I mentioned before right uh
is is compelling so
when a number of us see the go fast
it will compile it so it's just in time
right so it won't do anything until you
see it right so numbers see that oh you
want to run go fast which you used to
cheat so okay I will compound it so this
is the first time you call it it's the
time that when it got compiled so uh in
theory right in theory this should
actually take quite a while because it
is doing the compiling but how does it
compare to normal and how does it
compare to the second time so we got to
see that now so if you run this cell
so it's running yes
so you may have it a little bit
different because I'm using a very old
MacBook so yours may be faster if it's a
better computer
um so you see that uh
so without the compilation is this time
right it's it's quite fast
you know um but with the compilation
it's actually
it takes a long time so
uh so now you can ask the question right
like if if this thing right if this
thing I only use it once it may not have
a point like it it doesn't make sense to
go fast because it's actually not faster
because the time to compile actually is
quite long compared to no compilation
so again like number doesn't guarantee
that it's just going fast going fast
it's going fast because it compiles it
so you have to think that like if you
are not doing a lot of looping then
maybe it's not really helping you
um so the second time you can see that
oh okay actually you can see it's a
magnitude it's like minus five there's a
magnetism so this is one two three so
this is minus uh four this minus five so
there's a magnitude faster with the
compilation compared to no compilation
so so this so this is just an example to
show you that
um sorry typo
question okay cool
ER does the compilation and then runs
the body fast it doesn't like run the
body like I'm tracing or something
so it so this uh so this whole function
got so this whole goal fast function got
compile
so the first time when a number sees it
that you want to run go fast so if you
if you never go fast in your in your
code actually nothing happened but in
this first time say oh you want to go
fast and it's just okay I'll compile
that that's why it's low but and then
after that the second time you see how
fast this is so if you run it 10 times
then the first time is slow but then the
other nine time is kind of catching up
comparison because I've got a function I
did use number in and it takes like five
minutes to run even with number I want
to verify that like it actually is
running those five minutes or num are
the compile code not
python version First
ah I would have to have a look because
this is we're just we're just like
touching the basic basic so so yeah like
your code may be using it depends
whether you're using no python mode or
object mode also like again like if you
say it's very slow because you have run
it let's say 10 times but maybe the
compilation takes even like longer than
nine times doesn't catch up or something
like that so we can have a look of it
like later when we have time or maybe
when you go through all of these and
then the mystery start to like you know
be cleared up and things like that's it
uh save the question for later and we
will have a look yeah okay
so
um
another thing that uh is a little bit of
like tricky that like I want people to
be aware before we moved on is that um
in using numpy right numpy the vanilla
numpy uh a lot of times as a good numpy
user we would do a lot of vector or
array operations we won't do like Loops
to a little bit like element by element
uh
I just assumed that like let's just
let's just look at it together right uh
element-wise operation in numpy is
actually slow because
um
lumpai actually got a lot of you know
the C code that actually boosts the
performance because
those are written for a array or uh
Vector operations so
um
so if you if you're using like numpy not
with the wet operations you're using it
maybe not the best weight not optimally
so
um let's do some experiment to compare
those like vector operation and
non-vector operations
so uh we have a huge whoa yeah we have
huge array here is like quite quite a
big one and uh we have a uh an operation
here we're just calculating you know
like the cosine squared and the PSI
Square you know uh plus is the um so I'm
so bad with all the terms again
trigonometry like trigonometric identity
so you know like the triangle there's
like these two sides and the square
equals that that's I squared that kind
of thing right so we're doing that so
uh this is again we have a vanilla
version we are not doing any speed up so
let's see how long does it take so this
time we're using time it the time it is
a uh it's a magic uh command in uh no
Jupiter lookbook that it will time that
sell for you so what it does is actually
we'll run it multiple times and give you
a average so um
so yeah just just to be aware of that
for now you'll see why we do it this way
so
let's run this and have a look
yeah you see the time time itself take
quite a while to low because
uh Jupiter number is doing some
experiment and you're like running for
multiple times for seven runs for
example in this case and then if you
report a average with the standard
deviation for you
so we say okay so this is how long it
takes if we're using it as a vector so
we use numpy operations we use the
cosine operation and the sine operation
so I'm treating this array
so this array will be the X-ray so this
array us
a vector
so this is how long it takes so let's
compare it to
doing things element by element so see
how long it takes actually let's not run
it because it's very very slow uh you
can run it at home it's actually take
quite like a few minutes to run or we
can run it and move on and look at it
because it just take quite a while
it's 10 times lower that's how I try at
home it's like 10 times so if you don't
trust me you can if you have time you
can try it
um
but yeah like it's remember this style
already take a while to run and then
this one is 10 times lower it will take
a few minutes so let's ignore it for now
um
so
we may have to stop it to move on
I don't worry about this let's stop it
you can run it later just trust me it's
10 times slower okay so now let's let's
do it with jit so okay so with Jade and
we are again like just reminding you you
can use engine uh
instead of cheat no no question because
it's true but it's up to you they're the
same uh
you just you know choose whatever you
prefer
so now we're doing exactly the same
thing but this time we are compiling
them so
import The Decorator and then you know
run the now I add the engine at the end
so I know what this is
but before I time it I would compile it
first because I want to see the
performance after the compilation
because again the compilation will make
it uh so what
it depends because sometimes you want I
really want to know if I do it 10 times
like how long does it take right so yes
yes then you include the compilation but
if uh now I'm just like doing the
performance I would prefer to compile it
first and then I will see uh the the
time it how long does it take
so
um so now we see that it's like 248
milliseconds so it's quite fast compared
to this one
which is like 461 so it's
uh it's like half the time ish it's
quite fast but it's not as good as this
um
there's the speed up that we have when
we do this element-wise operation
because again remember that number is
really good with looping so when we have
the loop so originally this thing is
super slow and it's like you should
never never do it but now but because
like for some reason right you may have
to do it
um then then number can help you so
let's see so this one it's
it's almost the same time as this uh
this operation the the one with the a
vectorized operation
so you see
um the four is ten times lower I don't
even like have the time to run it you
know it's like very very slow
but now you see these two actually more
or less the same time it's even faster
this one two to three Ms oh well there's
a standard deviation there so maybe
maybe let's say more or less the same
so with number actually the element wise
operation and the vector operation
become
more or less the same time
so you can you may be able to take
advantage of it if you have like a lot
of loop if you can do better operation
you can only do element my operation so
this time that number may be able to
help you
it does seem that um
plain vanilla vectorized
as roughly the same speed as the
number entire living so you mean the
compile one the vector compile vector
and the vanilla vector
or these these two versions these two
number versions
so what's the speed
it's a 461 but but that is quite a huge
standard deviation so so like I would
say marginally maybe half the time or
maybe like one third faster yeah so it's
not a lot of speed boots because the
vectorized operation is already very
optimized by numpy itself so uh so so
that's why like uh you may found oh why
number doesn't really help me to go very
fast that may be why you know because uh
you you may be like you know you say it
would be a little bit faster but still
you know it you may not see a difference
because it's already optimized that's
why
um
so another thing that num uh number
maybe help you is that uh there's this
just very very like uh I mean a very uh
techy thing right like there's this
compilence so I was like oh what what
does it mean so I look it up you can
also have a look of it in Wikipedia it
just means that when people designing
the chips and have these like operations
uh very very low level machine code
operations there are certain things
certain compilers they have to follow to
make sure that
um the Precision is
achieve so no you know if you say the
Precision is that it's like definitely
that no position will be lost because of
the
the acrosmetic operation
but that thing actually would sometimes
make your code quite slow because it has
to follow that components it has to
follow that order
so uh number provides something called
Fast Math which means that if you don't
care that much about the Precision again
like if you are calculating the rocket
to the moon of course they need to be
very very precise but if you're handling
the data that actually
the Precision is not the most important
thing or you just want to quickly get an
idea and maybe some kind of
quick POC a quick uh graph to present
just a rough idea you don't need to have
that Precision so
fast math may be able to help you in
that case
so uh so again we're doing some
comparison here and let's see you know
the magic
so now we have two uh one is like not
doing fast math they are both using the
no python you know the engine mode which
is already fast but uh so we're just
trying to see the difference between
with fast math and no fast map here
so uh let's let's run it and see
so again we have to compile them because
like the compilation I let's not care
about that too much here let's look at
the compiled version the difference
between them
so you can see that uh to do some fast
actually very interesting because they
do some fast uh is it got a little bit
like maybe a few percent performance
improved but
it's quite consistent the the standard
user is quite slow it's quite low so
um so this example is a bit silly just
like adding oh adding the square root
and things but imagine if you have a lot
of data if you're doing more complicated
things that that may actually help you a
little bit
so uh almost half the time well the
experiment I did was really good maybe
it's not always half the time so maybe
let's try again maybe
it was a very bad conclusion that I draw
there yeah it's not not half
anyway uh it's just faster for sure but
you know maybe not that not that not
half the time so
yeah okay this is questionable I'll make
a question mark here so I would I would
uh be better next time so
multiple calls so this is a thing that I
have been looking into recently I've
just given a talk last week about using
the Nokia python which also trying to uh
trying to make use of multiple core but
I won't go into a detail there that's
like another talk so it's not here but
um the idea is more or less the same is
that nowadays most computer well even my
old laptop right like 2015 and see how
old it is it's uh it's still do cool so
I'm sure that you have computer now
there's like quad core or X coreless
like correlates like common it's not
rare it's not like you have to go to the
laboratory to find that so
um
in number actually provide you the
option to go parallel which uh means
that it will
make use of multiple cores right so
compared to python in Python you know
vanilla python we have the the global
interpreter log the Q so it needs to be
single threaded
I think number Pi because numpy used
some C code and stuff so it may already
be a little bit optimized but just in
case you know uh number also give you
the option to do the parallel
use of multiple core so
again let's run it so to see
why is it it's so weird why is it so so
long it's so different from what I do
like when I was at home
so uh you can see that it's like
95.3 milliseconds so this is running the
uh the the the
trigonometry thing right so let's look
back into the vanilla trigonometry how
long does it take
so
is is he no yes
for a second let me find it
so it's here
how much faster
there's like 461 so that's 95
it's quite fast actually
if you look at the Jade version without
parallel
is
148 compared to 95.
so um
it's it's good so if you have a better
computer than me it's maybe even faster
so
yeah so I think that that's that's like
as far as my flow can let me go so
I would unfortunately I would have to
let you finish the second or the third
one by yourself
um so in the second one we'll do some
like cab troubleshooting debugging
things so if you have a function that
doesn't compile
what should we do I hope that
um
notebook will help you to find the right
you know to to be more confident to
travel soon next time when it happens to
you and the third one is just that we
are trying it on the numpy uh tutorial
in the numpy website to deploy some
factors to make it uh to this number to
see if we can make it faster so
um I think just just just work on it and
let me know if you have questions I have
to um rest now for my clothes so thank
you
[Applause]